now last night i predicted that most
democrats
would glean all the wrong lessons uh
from the republican victories and today
i was proven right
the progressives were back at it on
capitol hill today instead of hitting
the brakes on their radical spending
spree they want to slam on the
accelerator
does it change the agenda for
the house
is paid family leave going back into the
bill without joe manchin's
okay you know i'm just i'm so excited
that it is going back into the bill it's
been a priority of the progressive
caucus for a long time and we're
thrilled i think terry mcauliffe has
been saying for weeks that his fate was
tied
to the progress of
negotiations here on capitol hill
and there ought to be a clear message to
my party senator what went wrong last
night
failure to deliver
okay well all wrong you know they're
still misreading the electorate bernie
sanders was not elected president biden
was
now sure blumenthal's right there was a
failure to deliver but mcauliffe turned
out a record number of democrat voters
but the problem was republicans came out
in bigger numbers
and not for spending trillions on new
entitlements or amnesty for illegals an
end to our energy independence none of
that
now this was one of my favorite
exchanges of the day with a liberal it
was a progressive member of the house
appropriations committee now even the
cnn anchor seemed exasperated
what lessons can be learned in your view
from the virginia race number one thing
is they wanted democrats with majorities
to get something done but you didn't get
it done before the virginia race because
progressives were holding up the
infrastructure reporters i saw i'm a
journalism major the only people who ask
me when we're going to pass the bill are
reporters the infrastructure bill could
have actually made it was passed in
august it's been what four months so
that could have actually
created thing you could have democrats
could have said they passed something
because you guys are all an anxious sort
i understand you're saying that you can
run on a message of um
let me finish up go ahead yeah it's a
lot easier if i'm allowed to talk to um
i have been giving you plenty of time
you needed to get both bills done to get
that done and we now have payton family
medical leave for four weeks in the bill
and a prescription problem you know the
senate isn't people will feel that what
we call this is the storm before the
calm
okay
the man sits on the appropriations
committee
and he thinks next year is going to be
the calm
because we're going to spend trillions
of dollars
and eventually just make energy more and
more expensive for the average american
and by the way magically the new climate
corps will miraculously make inflation
disappear is that a great trick
now voters in virginia and new jersey
are not stupid they know what nancy
pelosi and chuck schumer and dick durbin
the whole crew want to do
and they know it's going to cause more
inflation and lower the standard of
living for everyone but the very rich or
the very well connected
suburban moms cared a lot about
education for sure but the economy
supply chain issues empty stores on
christmas
that bothers them a heck of a lot too
democrats managed to even lose
75th house of delegates district in
virginia which is majority black
of course the very forces that drag the
democrats down though are still betting
it all on the race issue
yunken played the race card for a reason
because he knows it works on certain
white voters racism raised his ugly head
and the republican candidate used it
very aptly they're feeding them anger
they're feeding them resentment some of
it was
dog whistle racism
okay it's time for biden impersonation
it's not working
the example of the jamaican-born winsome
sears you just saw her on sean hannity
is virginia's new republican lieutenant
governor
she makes them all look like frauds
oh and if
someone a few were talking about
cuban-american jason mayares who won the
race for attorney general in virginia
now both are firsts in the old dominion
but of course we know democrats only
prattle on about firsts
when they're on their team
the populist conservative movement was
already gaining hispanic support under
trump and that support is only growing
sean trendy of real clear politics noted
that
so the shifts in new jersey should be
much more concerning to democrats than
the more or less uniform swing we saw in
virginia biggest swings from 2017
are in heavily hispanic areas now we're
going to talk more about the hispanic
issue later on in the show
but somehow democrats conclude that the
way to stop the bleed with hispanic
voters is to spend hundreds of billions
of dollars on climate change and
universal pre-k
and how exactly will hispanic small
business owners and there are thousands
and thousands
stay fully staffed when democrat
policies will just make it easier for
people to stay home longer
my friends this is sheer madness
trump's pre-coveted economic success
demonstrated how to do it he did it
the fact is democrats long ago low lost
touch with the beating heart of america
which is its middle-class blue-collar
workforce
their jobs were exported overseas and
the old establishment didn't care
frankly of either party
their fathers and sons are now dying
from drugs crossing our southern border
they don't care
they're losing their jobs because of vax
mandates but the democrats don't care
their favorite tax mandates
and now these same blue-collar workers
are struggling to fill up their gas
tanks
and no one on the left cares
perhaps democrats should remember what
happened the last time they rammed
through their dream legislation despite
having zero republican support
you see all that red you see all that
flashing at home those are republican
pickups and we are nowhere near finished
we do know the republicans will win more
than 50 seats most likely more than 60
seats and wolf it is everywhere it is
north south east west liberals are being
beat moderates are being beat it is a
shellacking
the 2010 results were a total rejection
of the partisan passage of obamacare
but obama himself didn't try to dodge
responsibility
yesterday's
vote confirmed what i've heard from
folks all across america
people are frustrated they're deeply
frustrated with the pace of our economic
recovery
and
the opportunities that they hope for
their children and their grandchildren
and as president i take responsibility
for that
now today of course his veep for eight
years refused to take any responsibility
do you take some responsibility i'm not
sure that i would be able to have
changed the
number of very conservative folks who
turned out in
the red districts who were trump voters
but maybe maybe
no i i i know we did but i we also i was
running against donald trump
i'm like that that is such an
embarrassing answer
but while the democrats willful
ignorance is a boon to republicans and
it is
it's going to be terrible for the
country
those who least deserve to suffer will
be forced to suffer those who least
deserve a big payday will get one
but a year from now all americans will
have their say in the midterms
and the day after the same experts who
keep getting paid to be wrong will again
try to explain away the democrats defeat
never acknowledging that it's because
their policies are destroying the
american dream
it's the definition of insanity and
that's the angle hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else